This is the Chris Abraham Show.
Good morning.
This is Chris Abraham, The Chris
Abraham Show, Season five,
Episode season five, episode 39.
And coincidentally, I received
my really cheap 70 something
dollars on sale.
Blacked out Nike Pegasus 30
nines in size 14 because I can't
fool myself.
My feet aren't happy in size
thirteens anymore, so I'm size
14 Nike Pegasus.
I was realizing that I could
walk in Nike.
Size 13 Pegasus.
But I couldn't run in them
because when you run, your feet
swell and that is no bueno.
So here I am walking again
today, probably saying something
garbagey, except the fact that I
think today is National
Hamburger Day.
Maybe, and that's good.
So I will have hamburgers today,
but without the buns.
And I'm off to get my espresso
and water from Starbucks and to
get some sun now, because
today's officially a heat stroke
warning day that Alexa just told
me.
So keep hydrated, get
electrolytes, stay out of the
sun and all that fun stuff.
Try to find air conditioning if
you're in the day.
M Va.
I just tweeted something that
might be controversial if
anybody cared, but nobody cares
about anything I say.
And I was listening to the Glenn
Beck Program like out of
nowhere, just during my shower I
said Alexa play the latest
episode of the Glenn Beck Show.
And he was talking of course
about climate change.
And I went on a Twitter and all
my other social media platforms
and I said.
Remember when we worshiped raw?
Remember when we worship the sun
and the Pharaohs told us that if
we did not appease them and give
them all our money, or give them
all our wealth, give, give, give
to the Pharaohs of our grain and
of our calves, and of our lambs,
and of our goats, and of our of
our.
Fruits and vegetables and even
of our children.
If we didn't do that, if we
didn't contribute till it hurts,
then there would be pestilence
and sickness and hunger and
famine and death upon the land
if you don't give your money to
the Pharaohs.
And the Pharaohs will appease
RAW the sun God.
If you do not do such things,
then many people will die, and
the blessings upon our land will
have ended, and RAW will reward
us with sickness and death and
famine, and hunger and thirst
and pestilence.
And terror.
And so I said in the end of the
tweet, I'm like, that's totes my
goats not totally happening now
with climate change.
I promise it's totally for real.
Like, no joke, The Sun God RA is
not who we think is coming down
and destroying the earth.
And making us warmer, and
bringing us into sadness and
mirth and dejection and
rejection, and into sin, and
into famine, into hunger, into
death, into heat stroke, into
death, into migration, into
famine and sickness and turmoil.
And if you give?
If you give to the Pharaohs,
though, if you give to the
Pharaohs, the world will be
better.
But if not, the end is nigh.
Whether it's 2030 or 2040 or
2050, there will be great
collapse, There will be great
sadness, There will be gnashing
of teeth, There will be rending
of sackcloth and billions and
billions of people.
Will perish under climate.
I mean raw.
I mean climate.
I mean man's awful, awful
contribution to the heating of
the Earth.
And when the Western scientist
was taken by the cannibal
Pagans, and he knew from his
Almanac that that day would be a
full eclipse, he told the Pagan
cannibals.
Behold ye Behold ye God is
displeased.
God does not favor thee upon
today if you do not release us,
If you do not release me, God
will blot out the sun.
God will let out the sun and
taketh away from you that which
you worship.
That which gives you warmth,
that which gives you food.
And then the Pagan cannibals
were were scared, but they were
confident that there's no way
that this man knew the mind of
God.
And surely this, this, this
alien from outer space had no
control over the sun.
Yet at 3:00 PM exactly, the sun
was blotted out as if upon
command.
And they did they did release
him, and upon release, and the
promise of his release and that
he will not be molested.
Yes, the sun did come out from
its hiding for when God
released.
When the Pagan sun, worshipping
cannibals when they doth,
released this man and promised
him safe passage forever.
The sun then returned within
minutes, as though beckoned by
the man who thus called out to
the sun and said God, They know
not what they do.
I will release the sun back to
these humble people and give
them the warmth and nutrients
and nutrition that they need.
Amen.
And so that parable has nothing
to do with the fact that
scientists might not, might
completely and totally know
about the natural process of the
Earth.
And the warming of the earth and
the changes in in natural
climate and are telling us that
if we do not turn away from our
sin which is capitalism and
consumption, materialism,
pollution, internal combustion
engine, easy travel, easy
convenience, modern convenience,
A/C heating.
At will affordable vehicles,
modern conveniences?
If we don't turn against that,
then the sun will be will be
blotted out.
And is it because the Almanac,
The Almanac, The Almanac
predicted that?
Or is because in fact the
wrathful and fickle?
God of the Sun who isn't a blind
watchmaker but is in fact paying
attention to colonialists,
imperialists as they enter into
quote UN quote Pagan
cannibalistic villages.
Is he paying deep attention or
did the?
Adventurer the scientist.
Did he in fact just have
information that the primitives
didn't have?
Anyway, I am lucky because I
actually got out here before we
all the construction was going
so.
I think things are.
Hi, good morning.
I think things are going well
for this and after that show,
totally unplanned.
After that crazy show, I have to
admit that I'm not going to park
run tomorrow.
One of my clients has a meeting
scheduled for 10:00 or 11:00 AM
tomorrow, Eastern Time.
So I will have to beg off.
So this morning I feel like I'm
a total flake now man, I had to
give up my volunteer position
with only like 24 hours advance
notice.
So I feel like that puts the the
smite on me and I wish that
weren't the case.
So I'm very sad about it.
I hope this is not a weekly
meeting.
I hope I'm not beholden to them
every Saturday because then I'm
going to have to fire them
because I want to do park run
more than I want that particular
client.
Anyway, I am approaching Shea
Starbucks and they have
sustenance for me and they have
caffeine.
They have Drogas, Paramine
Audio.
And I love you and I'll talk to
you soon.
Mahalo.
Bye, bye.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.